by now i think everyone has heard of
what happened in uvalde texas
i'm not going to go into detail and new
facts are coming to light every single
day
but one thing it seems is certain is
that the police
to put it charitably did not act in a
way that most people wanted them to act
by all accounts there was a very long
delay between the time that the police
arrived on scene
and when they took action to stop the
shooter so people angry at the tragedy
are asking can the police be held
legally responsible not for their action
but for their inaction and i'm not gonna
hide the ball on this one the answer is
almost certainly no
but the reason why
might surprise you because most people
believe
that the police have a legal duty to
help
and unfortunately according to the
supreme court
that is not the case while their motto
may be to protect and serve the police
have absolutely no duty whatsoever
to help anyone that's in trouble now
normally this would be the part of the
video where i run through the factual
summary that gives rise to all the legal
issues i'm not going to do that today
because honestly it's just too hard but
these are important legal issues and
this is one of those videos where
it's not about what the law should be
it's about what the law is now we've
talked a lot on this channel about the
difficulty in suing police for the
things that they do the mistakes they
might have made
qualified immunity generally protects
police officers unless it was clearly
established that what they did was
unconstitutional
there are all kinds of controversies in
this doctrine this is not the video for
those particular questions but the
question presented by the uvalde
shooting is different here we're asking
whether government officials can be sued
for actions they did not take
now the supreme court has ruled twice
that government actors like police and
social workers actually have no duty to
protect anyone this president was
established in 1989 when the supreme
court decided the case of descheney vs
winnebago county department of social
services
in that case in 1982 joshua deshaney was
a four-year-old boy living with his
father randy in wisconsin randy had
primary custody of the child and had
recently gone through a second divorce
joshua's stepmother told the winnebago
county department of social services
that randy abused his son randy denied
it and the county took no action to
remove the child however in 1983 joshua
was seen at the er for bruises the er
doctor notified social services and
joshua was removed from randy's custody
for a few days randy wasn't charged and
the child was returned to his custody a
social worker was assigned to visit the
home and in 1984 the social worker
visited the house 20 times noting that
the child had bumps bruises and injuries
on his head the social worker also
documented that randy failed to attend
his regular counseling sessions or
enrolled joshua in preschool and during
this time joshua ended up in the er
twice with suspicious injuries the
social worker said that she feared for
his life but took no action to remove
him from the home and unfortunately in
march of 1984 one day after the social
worker's visit randy beat joshua so hard
that he fell into a coma joshua had
severe brain damage and was permanently
paralyzed the state then placed joshua
in an institution where he would remain
for the rest of his life joshua
duchene's mother sued the winnebago
county department of social services
alleging that the department had
deprived joshua of his liberty interest
in bodily integrity and violation of his
rights under the substantive component
of the 14th amendment's due process
clause by failing to intervene to
protect him against his father's
violence now the due process clause of
the 14th amendment declares that no
state shall deprive any person of life
liberty or property without due process
of law the shani argued that the county
had a responsibility to protect joshua
because it knew randy abused him the
social worker had tracked the abuse on
paper for over a year the shaney argued
that through the social workers visits
the state had established a special
relationship with joshua that created a
responsibility to protect him from known
dangers then chief justice of the
supreme court william rehnquist wrote
the majority opinion which found that
the due process clause only applies to
states not to private citizens since
randy was the one who beat his son the
court reasoned that the state didn't
directly cause joshua's injuries and the
majority also rejected the argument that
the state made joshua more vulnerable
the purpose of the due process clause
was to protect people from the state not
to ensure that the state protected them
from each other the court held that the
14th amendment did not grant any citizen
a guarantee of quote minimal levels of
safety and security the court also said
that people have no right to
governmental aid the court held that the
due process clause would only apply if
the state had assumed custody of a
person against their will and then
failed to provide for their safety and
general well-being justice brennan and
the two other dissenters sought another
way they believed that since the state
had acted through the social work
department they assumed the
responsibility for the child's safety
the dissenter said that if the state had
never intervened then others in joshua's
life like his mother might have taken
other actions to get him away from randy
and basically in the duchesne case what
happens is that a mother is worried that
her son who's in the custody of the
father
is being abused by the father she goes
to the police
they send social workers out a social
worker visits 20 times sees lots and
lots of evidence of abuse
ultimately the social services doesn't
do enough and the child is horribly and
permanently injured by the the father
in large part because social services
allowed
the child to remain with the husband now
there are obvious differences between
what happened in uvalde and a social
worker who fails to remove a child from
a violent parent but that takes us to
the 2005 case of the town of castle rock
colorado versus gonzalez where the
supreme court applied the same rationale
to a case involving the police now in
that case jessica gonzalez had asked for
a restraining order against her
estranged husband there was a colorado
law that made domestic violence
restraining orders mandatory whenever
one party felt threatened and the state
trial court issued an order prohibiting
the husband from seeing miss gonzalez or
their three daughters unless it was
through a pre-arranged visit now just
one month later the husband kidnapped
the three children ms gonzalez had
direct evidence that he had the kids
because he confirmed it on the phone she
begged the police to search for her
husband right away since she violated
the court order now the castle rock
police department told ms gonzalez that
it could do nothing and told her she had
to wait until 10 pm to see if her
husband brought the daughters home
at 10 pm the police told jessica to wait
until midnight at midnight she went to
the police station to beg them to arrest
her husband an officer took the report
and then went to dinner a few hours
later gonzalez's husband went to the
police station and opened fire police
killed him in the melee and when they
searched his truck they found the three
girls dead in the back gonzalez's
husband had murdered all three that
night miss gonzales sued the castle rock
police department for violating her due
process rights and the 10th circuit
court of appeals found that she had a
protected property interest in the
enforcement of the terms of her
restraining order which the police had
violated but the supreme court reversed
that decision ruling that gonzalez had
no constitutionally protected property
interest in the enforcement of the
restraining order and therefore could
not claim that the police had violated
her right to due process justice antonin
scalia wrote the majority opinion he
reasoned that the state law didn't
entitle anyone to mandatory action by
police even though the issue into the
restraining order was mandatory under
colorado law restraining orders provide
the grounds for arresting a person the
constrained to the order but that
doesn't mean that the recipient can
force the police to act scalia wrote
that under the colorado law police have
discretion to decide whether to enforce
an order
and if so how they would do so the court
concluded that since colorado had not
created such an entitlement to mandatory
action gonzales had no property interest
and the due process clause was therefore
inapplicable the court ultimately
concluded that unless a legislature
specifically said
we're creating this right and if we
breach it the private citizen can then
sue the government then the citizen is
out of luck and as one court put it
quote law enforcement officers often
consider themselves responsible for
protecting the public and deterring
criminal activity however the legal
doctrine that specifies the legal duty
of law enforcement officers holds that
they have a duty to the public but not
to individual citizens
this is what's known as the public duty
doctrine the doctrine means that the
officers don't have a duty to protect
citizens from harm by a third party in
other words there is no clear duty to
protect individual citizens now that
being said the duscheny decision
recognized two possible exceptions to
the general rule that the state has no
duty to protect people from harm the
first is what's called the special
relationship exception which holds the
the constitution imposes upon the state
of duty of care towards individuals who
are in its custody as is usually
summarized when the state takes a person
into its custody and holds him there
against his will the constitution
imposes upon it a corresponding duty to
assume some responsibility for his
safety and well-being so when the state
has a special relationship with someone
there may be a duty to protect if this
relationship exists the state official
must take reasonable steps to ensure the
safety and care of that person and to
safeguard them against foreseeable risks
however most courts say that the only
time the state forms a special
relationship is through incarceration
institutionalization or other similar
restraint of personal liberty and most
courts reject the theory that people
waiting to be rescued are in police
custody and control this is particularly
true in the fifth circuit and perhaps
the most analogous fifth circuit case is
salas vs carpenter where a county clerk
was taken hostage at the courthouse by
her abusive boyfriend and during the
hostage negotiation the sheriff ordered
that this city swat and hostage
negotiation teams leave the courthouse
he then replaced them with county
personnel not trained for swat or
hostage negotiations
the man killed the county clerk and the
fifth circuit sided with the share
finding that he did not violate her
constitutional rights by using untrained
negotiators the court said quote
generally the absence of a special
relationship defeats any due process
claim based on a failure to provide
protective services the victim was not
held in state custody or otherwise
prevented by the state from caring for
herself this was a failed rescue effort
and it's easy to see how the fifth
circuit which covers texas would
probably make the same call in the
hypothetical uvalde case the police were
doing something they were securing the
parking lot and stopping parents from
getting inside where they might get hurt
and just because the effort failed and
failed badly probably wouldn't change
the fifth circuit's analysis but under
the descending case there is a second
exception and that is called the
state-created danger exception and under
that theory some courts have recognized
that state officials have a duty to
protect individuals from harm when their
actions created or exacerbated a danger
to that individual but here it seems
like this exception wouldn't apply the
police didn't help at least not in the
way that most people wanted them to help
but at the same time they also did not
create the situation itself now those of
you that have been paying attention
might have come up with a legal theory
that might differentiate what happened
in uvalde texas from the prior precedent
and that is that
children are mandated to go to school
often those schools are provided by the
government and in this case
this massacre occurred at a public
school so aren't the children within the
custody of the government and doesn't
the government then have an obligation
to provide for the health and safety of
the children especially a school that
has a police officer and a school
district that has its own police
department
well it's complicated but it probably
doesn't turn out the way that you might
want because unfortunately this is not
the first time there has been a massacre
on school campus and a relatively recent
case is almost directly on subject and
that is the case arising out of the
parkland situation in late 2020 the 11th
circuit court of appeals cited the
castle rock and shaney cases and
dismissed a lawsuit brought by the
victims of the parkland florida shooting
at the marjory stoneman douglas high
school now there the students allege
that the county sheriff and deputies
incompetently responded to an active
shooter situation violating their due
process rights the deputies knew that
the shooter was
a danger to the community and school
officials had also known that the
shooter was deeply troubled and had made
threats the plaintiffs allege that the
the deputies had failed to intervene
during the shooting and they also noted
that one deputy prevented ems from
providing life-saving care and blocking
them from entering the school during the
shooting the 11th circuit court of
appeals which is one step below the
supreme court found that a plaintiff
could only allege a substantive due
process claim in two situations first
when the person was in the government's
custody and second when a government
official's conduct is arbitrary or
shocks the conscience now first the
court held that the children were not in
police custody and as far as shocking
the conscience the court held that in an
active shooter situation police have to
make split-second decisions in the midst
of chaos in this situation quote an
official's conduct will shock the
conscience only when it stems from a
purpose to cause harm that means that a
plaintiff can only sue if they can show
that the government officer purposefully
caused harm if the police officer didn't
intend hurt anyone then they can't be
sued and with respect to whether the
children were in government custody
the court held quote it is well
established that school children are not
in a custodial relationship with the
state a custodial relationship exists
only if the government places
limitations upon individuals ability to
act on his own behalf that are similar
in kind to incarceration or other forms
of involuntary confinement school
attendance even when compelled by
truancy and compulsory attendance laws
is not similar in kind to incarceration
or institutional confinement ordinarily
there are no custodial relationships in
the public school system even if
officials are aware of potential dangers
or have expressed an intent to provide
aid on school grounds
and in the parkland case the biggest
controversy was about scott peterson a
broward county sheriff's deputy and
school resource officer peterson stayed
outside of a school building for over 40
minutes as students and faculty members
were gunned down and the state of
florida charged peterson with neglect
under a statute that applies to
caregivers now this is generally a novel
interpretation of law which usually
applies to parents or adult household
members or teachers now peterson will
stand trial on this criminal case but
the 11th circuit dismissed the civil
case against peterson for the same
reasons it dismissed the cases against
other defendants that these students
were not in a custodial relationship
with the officials even the school's
armed resource officer
a lot of people disagree with this
particular ruling and it can be solved
with legislation
but as it currently stands there is no
inherent cause of action based on the
constitution that would allow
parents and teachers and victims to sue
the police for inaction at uvalde and
unfortunately that is the current state
of the law now if you'd like to actually
do some good one thing i can recommend
is a company i work with called tab for
a cause which lets you raise money for
the charity of your choice just by
opening tabs while you're browsing the
internet tab for cause is a google
chrome extension that allows you to pick
a charity of your choice then every time
you open up a new tab instead of a blank
page it displays a new customizable tab
that displays a couple of tiny ads and
the money that you generate through
those ads is then donated to the charity
of your choice and you can see how much
you're generating in real time i've
worked with tab for cause for years and
legal eagle viewers have actually raised
over five thousand dollars for charity
just by themselves and it's great
because tab for causes finances are 100
transparent so you can see for yourself
how much you've raised and where it's
gone so if you're in the mood to do
something good for this world all you
have to do is click on the link that's
on screen right now or in the
description
and install the browser extension that's
it and then every page that you open
will create revenue that goes to charity
it's a little thing um
but
by a lot of us working together we can
make a tiny difference in this world